assalam
alayum may peace mercy and blessings of
Allah subhana wa taala be on all of you
now we enter into the next part of our
program which is the open question and
answer session which is the most
interesting part of Dr zakin nik's
program and it's also very interactive
and the audience will get the chance to
interact with the speaker and ask
questions on whatever Dr Zak has spoken
in this talk to analyze today's topic
adequately for the audience present here
today in the limited time available we
would like the following guidelines to
be followed during The Question Answer
session kindly state your name and
profession before asking the
question you can ask the question on the
topic as well as any question on Islam
and comparative
religion for your second question you
have to go back of the row and await
your second chance to ask a question
non-muslim brothers and sisters present
here in the audience will be given first
preference and I will request the
volunteers who are on the mics that
please check up if there are any
non-muslim brothers or sisters in the
queue then please give them first
preference and give them the first
chance to ask the question we have two
mics here one for the sisters on my
right and one for the brothers on my
left may we have the first question from
the brothers on mic number one my name
is Muhammad kab and I'm a A- level
student I know your profession and your
Specialties is in comparative religion
so my question is going to be on
Christianity um a lot of Christians say
that Jesus is god um can you articulate
any evidence uh using the Bible to
refute this claim um thank you very
much brother as the question that many
Christians claim that Jesus Christ peace
be upon Him is God so can you refute
this from the Bible before I give the
answer I would like to make a few points
clear that Islam is the only
non-Christian Faith which makes it an
article of Fai to believe in Jesus
Christ peace be upon him no muslim is a
Muslim if he does not believe in Jesus
Christ peace be upon him we believe that
he was one of the mightiest messengers
of Allah subhana wa tala we believe that
he was born miraculously without any
male Intervention which many modern day
Christians today do not believe we
believe that Evol the Messiah transed
Christ we believe that he gave life to
the Dead with God's permission we
believe that he healed those born blind
and lepers with God's permission the
Muslim and the Christians we are going
together but there is parting of ways
there are many Christians or most of the
Christians who say that Jesus Christ
peace be upon him he claimed Divinity
but if you read the Bible there is not a
single unequivocal statement in the
complete Bible where Jesus Christ peace
be upon him himself says that I am God
or where he says worship me if anyone if
any Christian can point out to me any
single unequivocal statement from from
anywhere in the Bible from any version
where Jesus Christ peace be upon himself
says unambiguously unequivocally that I
am God or where he says worship me I'm
ready to accept Christianity
today when we read the Bible we come to
know that Jesus Christ peace be upon him
himself said it's mentioned in the
Gospel of John chapter number 14 verse
number 28 Jesus Christ peace be upon him
said my father is greater than I Gospel
of John chapter number 10 verse number
29 my father is greater than All gospel
of Matthew chapter number 12 verse
number 28 I with the spirit of God cast
out devil Gospel of Luke chapter number
11 verse number 20 I with the Finger of
God cast out Devils Gospel of John
chapter number 5 verse number 30 I can
of my own self do nothing as I hear I
judge and my judgment is just for I seek
not my will but the will of my father
anyone who says I seek not my will but
the will of almighty God he's a Muslim
Jesus Christ peace be upon him he was a
Muslim he never claimed Divinity is
clearly mentioned in the Gospel of John
chapter number 14 vers number 24 Jesus
Christ peace be upon him said that the
words that you hear are not mine but my
fathers who has sent
me and it's mentioned in the book of
Acts chapter number two verse number 22
he men of Israel listen to this Jesus of
Nazareth a man approved of God amongst
You by wonders and miracles and signs
which God did by him and you are witness
to it a man approved of God amongst You
by wonders and miracles and signs which
God did by and you witness to it so here
when we read the Bible we come to know
that Jesus Christ peace be upon him he
never claimed Divinity he never said he
was God he said that he was a begotten
Son of God but he was one of the might
messenger of Allah subhana hope that
anwers the question thank you very
much I've got many questions on the
chits but uh Dr zaker always prefers if
people can come up to the mic and ask
questions and questions written on the
papers or paper slips will be given
second preference so please come on the
mic and ask question that would be
preferable
does it affect your
word the brother asked the question that
I live in a predominantly Hindu Society
does it affect my work yes it does it
helps me to strive harder mashallah it
does affect the place where I come from
Bombay it is supposed to be one of the
most difficult places where you can do
dawa
the Bombay City if anyone knows one of
the most difficult places where a person
can do dawa the organization the
political organiz that are there there
are so much against the Muslims but
Allah says in the Quran in Surah Imran
chapter number three verse number 160 if
Allah helps you then none can overcome
you if Allah forsakes you who is there
then who can help you so let the
Believers put their trust in Allah so if
Allah's help is there it's very easy
believe me in Bombay while doing da even
the life is in
danger
IND that's what I'm aware of it that's
what I'm telling you that's what I'm
telling you Bombay is the most difficult
place where get into dawa it's very
difficult yet in spite of living in such
a situation with Allah's help it is very
easy imagine I give talks from the past
8 years on the cable TV network we come
on more than 1 million homes every day
every day and in that we do hardcore
dawa quoting The Vedas quoting bhagwat
Gita quoting the upanishad Mahabharat
talking about the scriptures and
alhamdulillah when we give talks Hindus
also come in large numbers and we train
our people mashallah and the students
that we have and my colleagues even they
mallah can quote Quran Hadith Bible Veda
Raman even our children in school
mashallah if you see the Young children
in school in the fifth standard sixth
standard they can rattle off chapter
number verse number masallah they're
trained are you able
tol brother normally you should realize
we should follow the rules and the
regulation of question answer session it
is not a discussion you're having
between me and you fine you elderly
person we wanted to get the mic to
you the thing is that if someone gives a
finger should not catch that there rules
and regulations are there there at least
15 people standing in the queue there
and one question you could have asked
all the three questions together while
giving a talk if you interrupt in
between this goes against the rules and
regulations and a Muslim is supposed to
follow the rules and regulations if you
are a Muslim question interated so you
should ask together yes you should ask
together otherwise you should ask one
question go behind the queue and then
ask so you should wait for 15 people to
finish and then you can ask otherwise it
becomes a dialogue not that I cannot
answer not I cannot answer regarding our
last part because the elderly person I'm
answering were we able to convert anyone
we don't convert anyone Allah gives we
cannot convert anyone Allah says in the
Quran in number 88 verse number
21 our job is to deliver the message
it's Allah who gives and alhamdulillah
Allah has given to thousands of
non-muslims Mah to the we have been made
the and if you
see and if you see video tapes mashallah
I've given a talk on similarities
between Hinduism and Islam and mashallah
when we have in Bombay we only allow
non-muslims to ask questions nowadays
Muslims only listen Muslims are our
people they are not our guest the
non-muslims are our guest so M there's
so many non-muslims queuing up that even
though we give two to three ask for
question answer we can't complete all
the questions and masah many of them
accept Islam on stage and I was just
there yesterday in Birmingham there
there was a Muslim who told me that
there's a Hindu and Lester who's so much
impressed with the talk that he wants me
to come to leester he wants to call all
the Hindus of that area he will finance
everything he wants to keep my talk
similarities between Hinduism and Islam
and inshallah Allah may give him also
very shortly so the thing is that we
have to convey the message Allah gives
but we should not be afraid we should be
on lines of Quran and Sunnah and deliver
a message hope that aners the question
maybe we have the next question from the
little sister standing over there asalam
Alum my name is maram my question is if
someone does something really bad then
what does Allah recommend in the Quran
to give them a punishment sister asked a
very good question that if someone does
something bad what is the punishment
recommended by Allah in the Quran
depending upon the sin done we have to
realize that Allah subhana wa ta'ala has
got various ways of guiding the person
one of them as you mentioned is that if
someone does a sin then there is a
punishment for that on the other hand
that if you don't do that sin then
there's a reward for you so one of the
aspects is if you don't do this if you
don't drink alcohol there's a reward for
you if you don't Rob there's a reward
for you and the reward will be here also
in the but the point to be noted
depending upon the sin is the punishment
given but Allah says in the the Quran in
Surah chapter number 4 verse number 48
and Surah n chapter number 4 vers number
116 that Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala if he
pleases he may forgive any sin but the
sin of shik he will never forgive shik
associating partners with God Allah
subhana wa ta'ala will never forgive any
other sin if he pleases he may forgive
so we as Muslims what we should do that
if we see someone doing sin a beloved
Prophet Muhammad sallallah Ali wasallam
said that if you see anything wrong if
you can stop it with the hand stop it
with your hand
if you cannot stop it with the hand then
stop it with the tongue if you can't
stop it with the tongue the least you
can do is curse in your heart and then
you will be the lowest level of M
believer and Allah says that whenever
you see something wrong Allah says inah
Imran 3:
110 that enjoying what is good and
forbid what is wrong and believe in
Allah so if we as Muslims see someone
committing a sin we have to Da and is
with that person and tell that person
it's a sin you should not do it and try
and convince him with and Sunnah and
with reason and logic hope that answer
the
question I would again like to uh
request the non-muslim brothers and
sisters sitting in the audience to
please come up to the mic and clarify
your doubts and whatever misconception
you have about Islam this is your
opportunity so please please please come
to the mic and ask question and again
the volunteers standing near the mics I
would again request them to please check
up the queue if there are any
non-muslims standing in the queue bring
them forward so that they get the the
first chance to ask a
question may we have the next question
from the brother starting over there
assalamu alaykum Mr chairman brother
Nike uh I will explain who I am but
first thank you very much for your talk
and uh just to let you know that you and
Ahmed are always in my prayers I always
make Dua for you and uh when it comes to
public speaking I always try to emulate
you and Ahmed and it has helped uh with
the da my name is Hassan I a medical
representative for a pharmaceutical
company I'm also involved in the
political process I I stood for
Parliament last year and inshallah I
plan to go further in my career my
question is relating to uh educating
extremists extremist youth there is one
organization uh headed by a well-known
scholar who branded myself as a cafir
and other Muslims who uh got involved in
politics as cafair they use a quranic
verse which says that if anyone uh
legislates other than Allah then he
becomes a cfir they use these quranic
verses they also glorified the 911
attacks the question to you Dr Nike is
how do we educate these extremists who
claim to follow the Quran and the Sunnah
as the question that there is extremist
and the head of an organization who has
labeled him kaf they even glorify the
bombing and suicide bombing even 911 so
how do we educate these extremist see if
you're talking about Muslim
extremist then brother I call myself a
Muslim extremist I'm extremely kind I'm
extremely honest I'm extremely just I'm
extremely
merciful what's wrong in being extremely
kind Quran says be extremely honest I
can't be partly honest so I'm an
extremist Muslim we don't have to go
with the label the Western media
puts when they ask me I say yes I'm an
extremist extremely honest extremely
kind extremely just extremely merciful
extremely kind what's wrong and no
muslim can tell me that being extremely
honest is wrong the other people are
partly honest
partly just so what we have to do that
if he an extremist Muslim every Muslim
should be an extremist but extremist in
the right
direction not in the wrong direction we
can't be extremely unjust extremely
dishonest so if the media is telling
that there are some Muslims extremist I
say every Muslim should be an extremist
every Muslim should be a fundamentalist
if you're not a fundamentalist Muslim
then you're not a good Muslim you're not
a practicing Muslim so what the media
gives on us we get apolog I'm not a
fundamentalist I'm not an extremist so
I'm an extremist what you may be talking
is about Fanatics the difference between
a fanatic and an
extremist now I don't know who you're
talking about whether x y z So my answer
may be applicable to that person may not
be but our beloved Prophet Muhammad
sallallahu Ali wasallam said that if any
Muslim calls any other Muslim air then
that comes back to
him that means he becomes a kafir who
said a beloved Prophet M wasallam so if
you are a Muslim and if someone calls
you a kafir the person calling you
becomes a cfir according to of M
wasallam unless you have done Act of kuf
which he can really prove it Etc
otherwise the kuf comes back to him
coming to the question that how can we
educate those people who glorify these
attacks 911 London bombing Etc Allah
says in the Quran in Surah MAA chapter
number 5 verse number 32 if anyone kills
any other human being unless it be for
murder or for creating Mischief in the
land if any person Muslim or non-muslim
kills any other human being Muslim or
non-muslim unless it be for murder or
for creating Mischief in the land it is
as though he has killed the whole of
humanity and if anyone saves any other
human being it is as though he has saved
the whole of humanity so killing any
innocent human being is Haram it's
prohibited we know that in 911 in the
bombing of the New York Twin Towers more
than ,000 innocent people were killed in
London bombing more than 50 people were
killed last year just last month in
Bombay 11th of July 2006 more than 200
people were killed killing innocent
people is Haram anyone having even
little bit knowledge of Islam cannot
condone these acts should be condemned
it's Haram in
Islam but but there are many Muslims who
have said this especially in England and
USA I heard in front page but why you
putting a full stop there we also have
to condemn the thousands of people who
have been killed in Afghanistan the
thousands of people who have been killed
in Iraq the thousands of people who have
killed in Bosnia in
Gujarat why do we stop there when I
asked a person in America that why are
you putting a full stop but brother Zak
the situation is such we can't
continue what the city who are you
afraid of I live in Bombay mashallah a
city and a country which
we know that the life is in danger but
Allah M they to protect me
alhamdulillah and why do you put a full
stop where there no full stop why more
people have been killed in Afghanistan
than London bomas more people have been
killed in Iraq weapons of M destruction
did you find it no so why so why are you
keeping quiet who are you afraid
of why in the same breath we have to
condemn it no but the time is not right
what the time is not right so we have to
realize what is wrong has to be
condemned what happened in Gujarat has
to be condemned and if the people were
responsible for any evil act if you
catch that person and punish him no
problem you can't catch an innocent
person if someone has killed in Gujarat
you do a Bomb Blast in Bombay why
because the same Community Islam doesn't
permit that imagine those innocent
people who have been killed in the bomb
in Bombay or London or New York those
innocent people their relatives they'll
become permanent enemies of those people
who have done this yet the British
government has not found out who did the
London Bomb Blast yet no one knows who
did the Bombay Bomb Blast I'm not
telling you Muslims have done it anyone
who has done it whether Muslim or
non-muslim has to be
condemned a true
Muslim a true Muslim who believes and
submits to Allah will never do that act
if someone is caught which a Muslim name
he may be a Pudo Muslim May having named
Abdullah Sultan Zakir Muhammad that's a
different question question if it
happens to be whether he is a Muslim or
non Muslim he has to be condemned if
suppose imagine if suppose certain
Muslims think it is right the relatives
of the thousands of innocent people who
have been killed they'll become
permanent enemies of Islam how can we
condone it it's Haram what wrong have
they done what wrong have the people who
were traveling in the trains and Bombay
have done the people who were there in
the marketplace or in the tube where the
Bomb Blast took place in London so what
wrong they did do if you really can
catch the culit and punish him no
problem do it if you can't do it then
don't kill innocent people Islam does
not agree with that and I gave a talk is
Terrorism a Muslim Monopoly in
Birmingham
NEC and there I've told that if you go
to the US site US Department of Justice
on info please if you go on that site
there are many terrorist organizations
more than 50% of Muslims out of which
ulfa India had done 749 attacks in last
16 years more than any other terorist
organization that organization not
mentioned there why alqa has mentioned
28 attacks all suspects none
proved Ula 749 attacks all proven that
is not there on their site these acts
should be condemned we cannot kill
innocent people so you have to realize
that whoever telling that these acts are
correct they are totally against the
Quran and Sunnah ask them for proof no
what the Quran says if the culprit is
caught and if he's punished that's fine
but you can't K people thank you very
much I'm still receiving many questions
on slips from the sister's side uh let
me remind them that if they want their
question to be answered by Dr Zakir then
you have to come on the mic and ask
questions please sisters come on the mic
and ask questions thank you maybe the
next question from the sister dear
brother Zakir asalam alikum uh uh I'm
greatly honored today that I've got an
opportunity uh directly asking you a
question uh although until now I've I'm
only watching your DVDs and I'm a great
fan of your uh topics my question is
directly related to the topic that is
educating our children my question is
that in a proper Muslim education system
should any importance be given in
teaching our children about the national
identity or emphasis should be only in
religious identity don't you think that
by not teaching our children about their
own country's history uh the how it was
formed and how we got freedom from the
colonial prowers they will lack
Essential Knowledge about history of
their paternal roots and how IIs that is
your school which have students from all
parts of the world you are coping with
this side of Education are you teaching
only Islamic history or are equipping
their minds with ample knowledge about
their own respective countries as well
thank you s has a question that in an
ideal Islamic school should we even
teach about the country about the
national activity about National history
about the freedom fight and how are we
coping in is as far as the general
answer is concerned that in an Islamic
school we should even talk about the
country there's no problem at all we can
talk about the laws of the country we
can talk the rules and regulation of the
country but but we have to realize that
number one our Allegiance goes to Allah
subhana wa taala we should not go
against the country unless the law of
the country goes against Allah subhana
wa taala if the law of the country does
not go against Allah subhana wa taala we
have to follow each and every law of the
country as far as India is concerned I'm
aware that there is not a single rule in
the constitution of India which forces
any Muslim to do any Haram activity
neither does it prohibit you from doing
anything which is far for example the
Indian government doesn't say that
drinking alcohol is far optional so they
don't force you to do anything which is
Haram neither do they prohibit you to do
something which is far Salah is allowed
in fact they have a separate Muslim
personal law so I would say that among
the non-muslim countries in the world I
would put India to be among the top one
of the best countries where Muslim can
live I'm going disagree with certain
policies so I say I'm a very good Muslim
as well as a very good practicing Indian
but if any law of any country whether it
be India whether it be UK USA singapor
if it contradicts with the law of Allah
subhana wa ta'ala our allegiance to
Allah subh is more because he's our
creator he has given us life our country
has been beneficial to us may have given
us certain things job Etc but nothing
compared to our create Allah subhana wa
taala so our allegiance to Allah subhana
tala is more so if they don't contradict
we have to follow all the rules and
regulation if certain rules and
regulation contradict that particular
thing we need not follow so we have to
teach our children to be good citizens
also what's wrong you should be a good
Muslim so he should follow the rules and
regulations as long as it doesn't
contradict Islam as far as history is
concerned of course what we do that we
see to it sometime some history which is
not relevant we don't teach so then it's
at our Liberty we teach the history
which is required in our school Islamic
International School we have children
who are actually British Nationals but
they have parents parents also British
maybe the grandparents are Indian the
origin is Indian so we have students
from USA from UK from Saudi from other
parts of the world but basically all
have got Indian origion all of them so
you can call them Indians or you can
call them many of foreigners but but but
we have selected the world history we
have option of Indian history or world
history the world history we felt has
got more scope for us for doing dawa it
talks about the lifestyle of M sallah
Ali wasallam about Jesus Christ peace be
upon him about Moses peace be upon so
it's two in one so we selected the world
history we have two options world
history and history in world history
part of India also comes so what is
required we teach and as far as the
government is concerned of that country
we should be very bold what is right we
have to agree we can't say because it's
a non-muslim government I'm against it
for what if the policy against the
policy of Allah we against it if it's
for we have to agree even if the enemies
no problem we have to be bold that's
what Allah says in is
17:1 when truth is in falsehood
falsehood perishes for falsehood is by
its nature bound to perish so we should
see to it that in educating we have to
give them even the world history what's
happening in the world so that when they
go out they should be aware but some
which will not be relevant like some
things are taught which we feel will not
be useful for them they will never
requireed in the full life so that
portion we delete hope that answer the
question thank you very
much yes brother alikum Dr Zak my name
is y i a worker I got a two question
first of all I'm going to tell you I
love you because the way you are
speaking about Islam is terrific is very
nice and my first question is the place
where I'm working is like half and half
is like halal food is selling there and
Haram as well like kir Pig these things
if I'm working there about relating of
the money which I'm receiving what do
you think about that is that Halal for
me is that any sin on me or the second
question is uh
because when I start to see your
lecturing I wish in my heart that when I
see you face to face I would like to
give you a heart can I come to the stage
and give you a heart
[Applause]
brother as a question that he works in a
place which serves food part of it is
halal part is
Haram and the thing to be noted that is
it a business with sells food or are you
working in a place an office which
serves food for the staff or employees
so is it office no no I'm just a staff
yes if you're working in a shop which
sells Haram food and halal food if the
Haram food is in a very small
minority you know maybe the gross
turnover the Haram food may be 1% or 2%
then there can be possibilities but if
quite a large portion is Haram food then
you should not work in that shop it's
Haram you can't work in alcohol shop you
can't work in a shop with sell sport if
you're working in a festar hotel which
has got lodging boarding everything and
part the food is a small portion of the
income and in that food maybe 50% is
Haram then it may be fine working in a
festar hotel with the main income is
lodging boarding part of it is food in
that part maybe porke is Haram alcohol
is Haram Etc so in that case it will be
permissible but you're working in a shop
which sells only food and if majority of
the food more than 50% or even quite a
large portion 20 % or 20% I mean there's
no percentage per say but if it's
selling Haram food and we involved in
selling that then working in that shop
becomes Haram brother hope that answer
the question as soon as possible you
change your profession take a job
inshallah Allah will give you try and
find a better job and that will better
for your risk also and for
also alayum my name is Sagal I'm in your
six and my question is how can we start
educating ourselves in the Deep
so we may educate others in the um and
what is the basic we should know sister
has a question that how should we
educate ourselves so that we educate
others what should we know basically but
natural knowledge is such a thing that
it's a big ocean but the best book for
guidance is the Glorious Quran I would
ask you to read the translation of the
Glorious Quran that's the best this is
the best book of guidance it is a
proclamation to humanity it is the most
positive book in the world it is a
fountain of mercy and wisdom it is a
warning to the heedless it's a guide to
the earring it's an assurance to those
in doubt it's a Solace to the suffering
and a hope to those in despair the best
book that anyone can read for guidance
is the Glorious
Quran I have a question from a
non-muslim sister on the slip says I'm a
non-muslim girl and I'm considering to
revert to Islam but what this mean my
God In My Religion will punish me m
there's a non-muslim sister who was
thinking of accepting Islam may Allah
give a and we welcome you to the fold of
Islam alhamdulillah her main question is
that once she accepts Islam will her God
punish
her sister in all religions including
Islam God is only one there's only one
same God for all the human beings
there's no different God for Muslim and
Christian and Hindu and sik and Jews
there's one same God and I've given the
talk on concept of God in the major
world religions and all the religion say
that God is one he doesn't have any
images he's not begotten he's all
powerful so the God is the same so if
you accept Islam and all the religion
say if you read most of the major
religions their scriptures say that
there is a messenger to come whose name
shall be Muhammad whether they read the
Jewish scriptures the Christian
scripture the Hindu scriptures I don't
know whether you're a Christian or a Jew
or a Hindu But whichever religion you
belong to inshallah most probably even
in your religious book it will be
mentioned God is one it will be
mentioned that there is a messenger to
come whose name is Muhammad and he will
guide you to the truth peace be upon him
so even that God it's the same God they
different God if you accept Islam Islam
means submitting your will to God so
inshallah that God will be very happy
and he will reward you and inshallah in
your next life he will give you Jenna
yes brother alikum kamron Kia company
director uh brother jaak for coming
today uh my question is that mashah
you've established a model Islamic
school one that I would envisage in an
Islamic State but established in today's
world my question is unfortunately tens
of millions of Muslim children would not
be so fortunate to go to schools like
yours uh what do you recommend for our
children and all over the world the
Muslims who cannot have these type of
schools and also are all your speeches
uh and details of the school on your
website the question that everyone will
not be fortunate to study in that school
so how can people millions of Muslim
throughout the world what should they do
for children how can they get a similar
school and as far as information of our
school yes if you go to our website IR
f.net in that website you'll see a
separate section for Islamic
international school you can go there
and you can get the information as far
as SAR schools there are two options the
first option is very easy that people
can come see our school whatever
cooperation they want we can give they
can come and start in the city a similar
school but the success is very difficult
but everyone who says he wants to start
a school they may not have the same
management skill they may not have that
same passion all these differ and the
main is Allah's help so if Allah helps
you inshallah it's possible so one thing
is that you can start a similar school
which many people have but so far all
those people who have started as I told
you that close to about 5% 6% of what I
would consider we also have franchise
but the require for franchise is very
difficult very strict we require land we
require all everything it should be
funded by the local people the thing
should be funded by the local people our
criteria very strict if we want any part
anywhere else in India we want minimum 4
Acres land if it's on the sub of the
city two acres if it's in the Heart of
the City we require half the
construction cost everything else we do
various rules and regulations in spite
of that we have hundreds of offers we
first thought we will open one school
every year but then we decided that it's
difficult but once we started the school
we realized to manage was so difficult
we had to fly in and out from M to
chinai we sent our teachers for training
we sent our counselors everything so we
realize that it's possible but it's
difficult so therefore we said that
every 2 three years we start we have
plans next time to start in Dubai inshah
there have been offers in Dubai where
people said that we will give you land
there are people Liv in UK who have told
us there was a person in Manchester told
me I can give you 5 ACR land we haven't
taken the offer yet we
scrutinize the person offering and
everything and if you feel it's feasible
it's not a commercial Venture Point
number one the person donating that land
we say you give it and forget it don't
think of getting a return in the Western
Country everyone is thinking if I invest
£1,000 how much will I get see wherever
I go it's only in the Western countries
in USA Canada and UK where there's
tickets there nothing the concept of
ticket for talk how can I have a ticket
for Islamic talk so there's no concept
of getting tickets people call me they
say Dr Z how much will you charge to
come I mean they cannot afford me
believe me if I have to tell my fees
they can't afford
me mashah come you free maximum you can
pay my ticket my crew Everything Has
Come absolutely mashallah it's all paid
by us fine simple accommodation if you
can if not we manage it no problem my
time is more important
so this concept is different there in
eastern part of the world mashallah is
different so what we do it is not a
commercial Venture so anyone interested
if he gives he have to forget it he
gives something for the land he put
school we control it if we have a
franchise we are full control we also
tell in India the person who donated he
donated a land someone donated a land
which cost about 16 CR rupees it would
be how much maybe some million pounds
worth of land but we told him no
guarantee that your child will be
admitted you can give the land you can
start the school but no guarantee if
your child passes he'll get admission
there have been cases that people have
given us maybe a million dollar donation
one child was refused I'm very strict so
our conditions are very absolutely
transparent so if such conditions there
we scrutinize the person who's doing
when we have a franchise we see to it
the one the name is attached if irf name
is attached finish we see to that we
keep up to our name as a policy when we
go anywhere else we tell them don't put
our
name we will come but don't put my name
don't put my name as organizer the
moment you put the name as organizer
that means there surely going to be
problems for us so when we go and
support any other Organization for any
function we support a lot mallah but the
only criteria of our is we'll help you
but don't put our
name because we know we don't have 100%
control even 50% control we don't 90% Al
we don't agree unless we have 100%
control we don't agree putting our name
as organizers or sub
organizers the name comes that means so
if someone there are offers Mah from
different parts of the world for us to
start such schools and one thing when
the name is attached inshallah we are
going to start in Dubai we will keep the
fees more than the British schools and
the American schools inshallah we'll
compete with them we'll keep higher fees
than them there are people who can
afford when Allah has given them those
who can't afford we'll give 25% people
we give scholarship when Dubai inshallah
is our next Target where the fees
there's quite high of the British
schools and American schools but
inshallah we have plans to keep fees
higher than them and inshallah there'll
be more people flocking to our school
inshallah with Allah's help and main
thing is the quality for other people
you can start in your own capacity
whatever you have I know that M the
government fund schools
also but we don't normally take funding
from the government too much of
interference not a single penny here I
don't know if you can take and run the
school the way we are r no problem or
you start on your own start on your own
small way whatever way you can whatever
ability you have got start and make a
beginning whatever you can do at least
scratch the surface inshallah and insh
Allah will help you and you'll be
successful hope that answer the
question maybe we have the next question
from the sister Alum um I've got a
question from a non-muslim sister she's
asking um a number of verses in the the
Quran are canceled out by others can
these not be viewed as inconsistencies
or contradictions for example chapter
4:1 15 abated by chapter
24:2 sister asked a question the
non-muslim sister that there are some
verses of the Quran which are abrogating
or contradicting it's cancelled so does
it mean that how can there be a
contradiction if you read the Quran
there are no two verses in the Quran
which contradict I challenge anyone to
point out any two vers in the Quran
which contradict Allah says clearly in
the Quran in chapter number four verse
number 82 Allah
says do they not consider the Quran with
care had it been from anyone besides
Allah there would have been many
contradictions now in the Muslim umah
I'm aware there is a concept of
abrogation theory of abrogation known as
manuk and based on the verse of the
Quran of Surah Bak chapter 2 vers 106
and Surah n chapter number 16 verse
number 101 which says that Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala does not cause any
of his ayat any of his signs to be
forgotten he substitutes it with
something better or similar now based on
this verse there are many scholars who
have propounded the theory of
abrogation N and manuk people will say
what is Dr Z talking about that no vers
is contradict the Quran says the ver
will not contradict it will not
contradict any scholar says anything I'm
not bothered Allah is the highest number
one now if you read the verse of the
Quran you can analyze the verse of the
Quran in two ways one way is that the a
talking in the Quran are referring to
the earlier
scriptures maybe Torah maybe injil so
Allah says I do not cause any of the
Ayah the signs of Allah the previous
vers of the previous Revelations to be
forgotten but substituted with something
better or
similar something better and similar is
the Quran
now if you agree that the ayat mentioned
in the words is ayat of the Quran then
too I have an answer it means that Allah
subhana wa ta'ala has revealed one verse
of the Quran what was relevant for that
time and after that he revealed another
verse but that verse is not
contradicting it is giving more
information and the two verses given by
the sister of Sur n 4:1 15 and Sur n
chapter number 24 ver number two though
she hasn't mentioned the translation and
Allah's Grace I know the translation of
these verses not that Quran this is all
training it's not Quran it is practice
that I know what question are going to
come to me so we know the verses
masallah it's very easy it's not
difficult you tell the verses and even
our children Mah do the same
alhamdulillah Sur n chapter number four
verse number 15 says that if anyone is
caught in
fornication if any woman is caught in
fornication then keep her in custody in
house arrest like seclude her until she
dies or Allah ordained something else
and then Surah n chapter number 24 verse
number two says that as for the
fornicator person who commits
fornication give them punishment of 100
lashes now people will think is there a
contradiction if the first quranic verse
of Sur n 415 said that put the woman in
house arrest and a full stop then Surah
n of 100 lashes would contradict it says
that keep them in house until the die
all until Allah gives something else now
for this Allah has given two options in
the Quran for a fornicator there's 100
lashes and in the Hadith of s bukari for
the adulterer the punishment is thror
into death so this verse of the Quran
does say that Allah will give some other
punishment later on if that part wasn't
there there would have been a contadi
so there's no contradiction it says that
this punishment is
temporary later on Allah will reveal
something else similarly there are
Scholars who have written that there are
thousand verses contradicting some
Scholars then came to 500 Su I think
came down to 22 another scholar came
down to five I have verified those 22
and five also I have answered those also
alhamdulillah and one of them is this
what we realize in manuk and what
happens that Allah in some prohibitions
he has important stages and the best
example I give is of alcohol the first
verse to be revealed regarding alcohol
is Sur Bak chapter 2 vers 219 where
Allah says in
intoxicants there is loss as well as
profit the loss is more than
Prophet this verse of the Quran does not
prohibit alcohol it only says in
intoxicants there is loss and Profit the
loss is more than profit the next verse
to be revealed of prohibition was n 4:
43 which says that do not pray with your
mind befogged when you're intoxicated do
not pray that means it's a higher degree
now previously did not say it was Haram
it only gave you guidance in intoxicant
there is loss and Prophet loss is more
than Prophet next ver says do not pray
with your mind before when you're
intoxicated you can't pray now since a
Muslim has to pray five times a day
indirectly he can't have intoxicant the
full day in night option is there not it
thing you should have the final
prohibition came in chapter 5 verse
number 19 which
says oh you
believe most certainly intoxicates than
gambling dedication of ston divination
of
arrows these are Satan
handwork abstain from this handwork that
you may Prosper here the final
prohibition came now when this verse was
revealed barrels of alcohol intoxicant
thrown on the streets of Madina never to
be filled again then the final Haram
came now if you analyze many people say
that the last verse of Sur MAA CH 5 vers
number 90 has overruled Surah Bak 2 vers
219 is contradicting it's not
contradicting it is giving more
information the first verse only told
you there is loss and profit loss is
more even today the verse is applicable
that verse is even correct today even in
intoxicant today there is loss and
profit we as medical doctors know there
is Prophet but the loss is more than
Prophet the next verse says Don't Pray
when you're intoxicated even today that
is applicable today you cannot
Pray when you're intoxicated but the
last final prohibition doesn't
contradict it
encompasses for example I say that I
live in
UK fine then next day I say I live in
London third day I say I live in Harrow
now moment I say Harrow London and UK is
understood but my first answer I live in
UK was a general answer then more
specific I live in London when I say I
live in Harrow it is more specific it's
not contradicting my first answer so the
last prohibition that the alcohol is
prohibited is not contradicting that in
intoxicant there is loss and profit it
is yet there it's not contradict n 4:43
that you cannot Pray when your mind is
befogged when you're intoxicated so this
means there is more information the last
verse of the Quran if you follow that
the earlier two is automatically
followed it's understood so therefore
according to me and according to Allah
subhana wa ta'ala there is not a single
contradiction in the Quran if there were
any contradiction this book cannot be
the word of Allah subhana tala so I
disagree with anyone let him be the
greatest scholar in the world and I
challenge anyone whether Muslim or
non-muslim to point out a single
contradiction in the Quran they will
never do it and never will be able to do
it yes brother
my name is m Ahmadi I'm a researcher in
history political science and I'm
currently studying in computer science
my question is is pretending to Jadu or
or magic or by by whatever name you
would like to address it I won't go into
specifics but the certain family member
recently found a piece of paper in which
was supposedly some uh elements of
negativity which they felt was of of
this nature and uh they themselves uh
indulged in similar practices to um to
obtain a um a remedy for it believing
that you know this is wrong I was
wondering if we could um shed some light
on this matter well has a question that
what do I have to say about black magic
and what's the remedy as far as black
magic is concerned there is something
like black magic the Quran mentions that
in Surak mention Sur Bak there's black
magic it does exist but we should not
involve in Black Magic we should not do
it we should have faith in Allah subhana
wa tala and as far as the remedy is
concerned Le the last two Surah the
M andas were revealed for this these two
suras are the remedy for black magic now
see one thing is there that normally
whenever people think that something has
possessed first thing is Allah says ask
the person who has
knowledge
16:43 21 vers number 7 go to a doctor if
the doctor
doesn't tell you the treatment or cannot
treat the disease go to a psychiatrist
most of the people who claim to have
black magic they can be cured by doctors
and psychiatrist there can be
possibilities that actually a gin may
have come and black magic may have taken
place at that case you can follow the
guidance of Quran and Sunnah you can go
to a person who's an expert in this
field but I'm sorry to say most of the
people who are experts in this field who
claim more than 99% are fake more than
99% according to me it is my analysis
more than 99 person who claim that they
can cure black magic they are frauds the
moment you realize is asking from you
money that means he's trying to make a
fast bu do this do that give me so much
money ,000 2,000 he's trying to make a
fast bu out of it so there are people
who are experts in this field I know a
couple of them in Saudi Arabia Mah
they're very knowledgeable I don't know
if anyone else other ways so if he's
knowledgeable we should realize that if
he give the treatment from Quran and
sunah you have to go to a specialist who
specialize in the field hope that answer
the question
maybe we have an next question from the
brothers over here alikum Dr Zak my name
is Shahid I'm a Salesman like most
people I love you as well uh i' just
like to ask you the question could you
define what im and AA is cuz ultimately
we'd like to die with this in this state
and also um how this can be attained is
it only through dawa and if so through
which method of dawa cuz there's so many
different efforts the question what is
the meaning of IM what is the meaning of
AKA and if dawa then which method of
dawa imman means belief you can give a
lecture on Iman for 5 hours or 10 hours
so what I don't know you give a lecture
on that I don't know what do mean a you
have a in Allah subhana everything so
you can give a lecture on IM you can
give a lecture on AKA no reason is
because some people seem to say that the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam was
more than what he was so ask the
question now you ask what is can give
for 10 hour without
talking some people think that Muhammad
sah Ali wasallam is more than a man or
is more than a man
yes he's more than a man he's the best
human being that we have in the world
he's more than a common man but but I
know what a question is but he is not
Allah subhana tala he is a human being
he is far superior than any of us human
beings but he's
Bashar he is Basher the Quran says he's
like a human being he requires to eat he
required to sleep and he's dead he was
dead in Madina but he was one of the
best exemplary Muslims as Allah says in
the Quran in Surah chapter number 68
verse number four that verily thou are
standeth on the highest standard of
character Quran says in 33 verse number
21 verily in the prophet you shall find
the most beautiful pattern of conduct so
as a human being is the best exemplary
Muslim alhamdulillah but he was a
prophet of God when we worship we have
to worship Allah directly we don't have
to go through anyone we have to ask him
directly and no one else
as far as how to do dawa do da according
to the Quran and Sunnah as per the
guidelines laid down in the Quran and
Sunnah and if you go to our website
i.net you'll find a lot of information
on that hope that answer the
question I have a question from another
non-muslim brother he yoginder Singh
Mani he seems to be a sick and he asked
that can you please tell me the
similarities between sism and
Islam Our Sick brother has asked a very
important question question that what
are the similarities between sism and
Islam and there are a lot time will not
permit me to expound on all I'll just
mention in brief as you think that
Sikhism it's a religion of 10 gurus for
those who don't know and it was fed by
gurunanak sa in the late 15th century in
the land of Punjab in the land of fire
riverse and Guru nanak he was very much
influenced even by the Muslims he was
born in a chhatria family in a warrior
class Hindu family he was influenced by
the Muslims
many Muslims and the five k that the
sick always maintain is the K that uncut
Hair It Is the kunga it is a comb to
keep the hair clean it is the there the
bracelet the fourth is the K the long
under draws and the fifth it is a kpan
it's a dragger this is the identity in
short this was a brief about a s so
moment M see a person wearing a turbine
he identify therefore I always
appreciate that the people who keep the
label without any fear are the S
therefore if you hear my talk on if the
label shows they intend to tell the
Muslims that Mas the sik he's proud to
be a sik and even fought with the
Canadian government in the army they
said to shave off that he said no I will
not and he fought the case and they won
when I went to Canada the first time in
1996 it came as headline that a sik
fights a case in the Canadian Army and
he wins the case but we Muslims many of
us someone did something we sh off the
beard
why now coming to the similarity between
the Sikhism and Islam the Sacred Book of
the sik is the guru gr or known as ADI
gr and if you read the first chapter of
this ADI gr first volume first chapter
first verse is called as
japji and it says that almighty God he
is called as the
true he's the true not
created The
Fearless he's not
begotten and he's free from fear and
want if you analyze he's one he's not
begotten he's the Creator it is similar
to our chapter number 112 verse number 1
to 4 which
says says Allah only Allah Allah the
absolute
Eternal he begs not know
begotten nothing like him and in sism
sism does not believe in AAR meaning
that God has gotar it's a monistic
religion God in the unmanifest form is
called as akara and manifest form as
omara and there are various attributes
of almighty God given in the guru Gran
amongst them is he's called Asar that is
the creator same in Arabic as khik he's
called as perar the cherisher same as as
R he's called as Lord as R he's also
called as kareim the benevolent he's
called
ASE beneficient he's also called as vah
Guru one God so if you analyze there are
many similarities between the concept of
God and Sikhism therefore Sikhism
doesn't believe in idol worship doesn't
believe in AAR it's a monotheistic
religion and if we analyze Guru nanak
was very much
influenced even by S
Kabir and you find in the gr many
couplets also S one of them is
which means in times of trouble everyone
remembers God in times of Happiness no
one remembers God if you remember God in
times of Happiness why should trouble
touch you same as Allah says in number
30 vers number 33 that when trouble
touches man he cries out to Allah
subhana wa taala but once when the
trouble goes away he associate partners
with Allah subhana wa tala so if you
realize that sism is also a religion of
one God it's a monotheistic religion
does not worship those Scholars say it's
an amalgamation of Hinduism and Islam
and we realize that in the concept of
God it is quite similar to Islam and for
more details you can refer to my video
said concept of God in major world
religion have spoken in more details on
that hope that answer the
question in we'll just have the last two
questions uh due to lack of time and we
cannot continue maybe we have the next
question from the brother over here
asalam alikum my name is Fahad I work as
a computer programmer uh my question is
related to Islamic banking uh what is
meant when a certain Islamic Bank says
that they're going to offer a loan at an
x% APR is that not interest there ask a
question that he wants to know about
Islamic banking Islamic Banks offer loan
and they add a x% they call it service
whatever it is it not interest see
basically interest is Haram in Islam
there no less than any different places
Allah interest is Haram Allah clearly
says in Sur Bak chapter number 2 verse
number 2
78-79 that if you give up not your
demands for interest take notice of a
war from Allah and his so interest is
Haram now as far as Islamic banking is
concerned as you mentioned many Islamic
Banks which give loan point to be noted
that most of the Islamic banks that are
there I don't know if any Islamic Bank
which is 100% Islamic I don't know maybe
I don't
know in fact one of my interest to the
Islamic banking but the there are many
which are Mah quite a lot Islamic there
are many which are frauds also fine only
Nam take Islamic what we have to note
that we as L man if we can check up
check up if you analyze there is Islamic
system of mushara profit and law sharing
which is the best safest mushara means
you become a partner in it now other
aspects are the mud is there that is
Cost Plus in Cost Plus many of times
people falter and many of times it's
nothing but
catching the nose long cut you
know you say that it is nothing but
trying to make a gimmick so we have to
analyze and many fatwas are given on
this is allow that is allow which many
which I don't agree with also so when
Islamic Bank comes you have to
scrutinize who is on the Sharia board
just by name please don't go that's not
important what they do Etc so many of
the Islamic
Banks I wouldn't call them Islamic they
may very small percentage Islamic now in
the Islamic bag most of them to muda in
mudara there's a problem Cost Plus which
comes sometimes it's possible is there
that is high purchase is there which is
Islamic mushara is safe safe means if
they're following Islamic principles in
other parts we have to check up and what
we analyze that most of the banks they
falter and because they compete with the
normal conventional bank they keep the
same interest name is
different label is different but the
same so we have to be careful while
taking loan but as a hey man if suppose
you think it Islamic and you take it and
if they are doing something wrong out of
ignorance you have gone so the blame
will come on them not on you if you know
they Haram and then you go then the
blame will come on you so it is the
owners of the people running Islamic
Banks to check up whether they're
following what happened there are many
fatwas in this and fatwa shopping is
very easy you know what fatwa you want
to get so they go and when G will get or
Pakistan or India so they take fatwa
which is conven for them and then they
sanction it so you have to be careful
while Islamic banking is there not that
not possible possible very difficult
there are some banks I know which are
Mah good yet not 100% and they know it's
because unless you don't have the
central system of Islamic you can't be
100% so the thing that that there are
many Islamic Banks coming up we have to
check up whether Islamic or if is there
but there is a system which you can do
so you have to check up the functioning
how they do and then you have to decide
whether right or wrong hope that answer
the question
in we'll just have the last question
from the sister salum brother and my
question and there's a small comments
after it should British Muslims develop
a body for speaking to the media on
Muslim issues and I asked this question
because currently in this environment
the media are talking about basic
beliefs in our de and they're calling
upon different people who don't
represent any of our views about why we
are Muslims they're talking because
we're going to the mosques and we're
teaching our children they think this is
an extremist and when they ask their
brothers h Muslim brothers and sisters
to attend on TV these Muslim and
brothers say that we are moderate
Muslims I am not a moderate Muslim I am
neither an extremist I am a Muslim and I
would like that viewed over with one
voice by the Muslim Community not a
fragmented voice that's been conforming
to the Norms of this
Society has a question that should the
Muslims have a common body to represent
the Muslims of British yes they should
have a common body for British Muslims
for American Muslims for Indian Muslims
all the countries as well as one
international Muslim body also one
international which we don't
have so we should have a voice of own
better have one good United force and I
believe that you already have in British
known as MB Muslim Council of Britain
and I think you're doing a good
job not in the
media sorry I'm the I I'm aware of the
Muslim Council of Britain but as you
know media is manipulation they don't
Target the Muslim Council of Britain
they individually Target different
Muslims to represent Muslims the sister
said that the Muslim counil of Britain
is there but the media doesn't talk so
you create your own media that's what
I'm saying media will run after you you
know for me in
the BBC asked me to give comments the
CNN I don't give for my own reasons the
BBC the CNN the NDTV see when someone
throw stones at you raise yourself so
high the stone should not reach you they
want what Doctor Z has to comment but I
stay away from it for my own reasons but
you should come on the media I stay away
because already alhamdulillah my
programs are coming in so many satellite
channels mashallah every day 1 hour two
hours twice a day thce a day now I'm
afraid that when these people take my
interview of five minutes they may make
it short and may change my view that's
the reason I stay away and what I want
to say we have got so many channels
showing up program mallah no problem so
what we realize that we should have our
own media not only a body to represent
media we should have our own media own
media and that media should be
powerful so that the reason Mah we have
launched a satellite channel if you see
this peace TV about 7 months back in the
month of January 2006 on 21th of January
we launched our own Satellite Channel by
the name of Peace TV peace TV at present
mashallah it is reaching more than 125
countries in the world it is covering
all the countries in Asia in Middle East
as well as Africa and parts of Australia
the beam is seen in Europe but it's very
weak we require a big dish inshallah we
have plans to come on B Sky also
inshallah within the next few months
inshallah we'll come on B Sky it will be
a free to a channel it's the
it's the first of its kind in the way
it's a English Channel with
International channel it's not a
localized Channel talking only about one
country we have speakers Mah from
America from Canada from UK from
Malaysia from Saudi from India from
Pakistan mashallah it's not a local
channel it's International Channel
talking about comparative religion we
have programs of children we have
programs of family mashah interviews
debates TV talks and here it is that the
channel should be on Quran and Sunnah
when I started the channel the first
thing I said I prayed to Allah subhana
wa tala it was a dream and finally we
launched it mashallah and I said that
please don't let me do anything Haram if
I'm forced to do something Haram I
better shut down the channel than nun it
in a Haram way many people start a
channel they're good but then they
compromise you compromise first there's
no lady then lady comes with nakab then
without nakab then without hijab then
low neck and everything so we want
channels which are why should we see we
should not R after money no ad will not
come we care of hang for
heads you should not run after money
money should run after you you give
quality you should have faith in Allah
do you want Allah's help or do you want
the money and the pound and the dollars
what do you want say Allah is sufficient
problem is we have more faith in other
thing than in Allah subhana tala our
channel masallah to the core no music we
have sound effects masah Hal sound
effects we have Duff we have natural
sound effects and if you see it it has a
great impact M we have graphics
but Halal we have own committee and we
produce high quality you see these
cameras we have got six cameras from
Bombay normally in Bombay when you shoot
with nine camera we 50 staff here we
have got only 12 staff 10 actually of
the camera crew your limitation we have
the best of people M best of equipment
alhamdulillah now this is the digital
bet we have got high definition high
definition hasn't started yet there's no
channel in the world which is shooting
on high definition now so we don't
compete with Muslim channels we compete
with International Muslim channels and
the best so far in religious channel is
the god TV they are on 15
satellites they are reaching more than
225 countries 275 million people and we
are programming in such a way that it is
a spiritual edutainment channel
inshallah the next plan is to have a
separate channel in different language
English and Udu then have a news channel
inshallah but it will be international
news not local news not only of Bombay
not only of London international news so
that we can voice how many International
media do we have do you have any
international newspaper on do you have
international news magazine like the
Time Magazine news week where do we have
we have some magazine taken out by
Muslim which only Muslims read either in
Udu or in Arabic or in English only read
by Muslims what we want that non-muslims
should watch it so we can at least say
that alhamd our Channel mashallah even
the program that we have that 25% at
least mallah of the programs that I give
whether in India or other parts
mashallah here I feel more non-muslims
should come why I don't know so many
who's to blame that a publicity should
be towards towards the non-muslim
mashallah so even the channel that we
have sister we should have our own media
own newspapers own magazines own
Satellite Channel which convey the true
picture of Islam so that we can present
our view to the world and the H of Islam
hope that answer the question
ald I invite brother Yousef Chambers to
give the vot of thanks
for Dr Zak and I coming tonight and all
of you coming tonight contributing
tonight remember the educating the
Educators it doesn't stop after
tonight's event Dr Zaki Knight will be
in croen with us but he never finishes
answering the questions he's always got
the answers mashallah alhamdulillah and
I think you should make the biggest T
and all go
home and the third one t
there is none
greater than the
Creator
Allah
Allah there is none
greater than the Creator